alors on fait
en juin
edit nouvelle
de mémoire car mes talents
les jeunes
je descends de marée
la nation un
tous les ans on s'aperçoit que la clause
d' alerte est un peu dépassée et à
chaque fois on est avec nos sacs de
sable on essaie de se calfeutrer un peu
le cet engouement
derniers préparatifs pour l'un des dix
balles de paris
comme vous
le raid dans les salles en tant que
membre de la fiesta dunkerquoise
ce n'est pas tant la foule croissante
que l'accolade fait faire les branches
c'est un beau dire et il faut s habituer
il faut pas
à bousculer monde il faut savoir tenir
la foule derrière les jeunes ne savent
pas faire ça ça qui a changé sa réussite
ou du carnaval de dunkerque est avant
tout un carnaval d'acteurs et non un
spectacle folklorique à destination des
touristes mais pour jacques le succès
c'est le prix à payer pour que vive la
bonne vieille tradition dunkerquois pure
souche on regrette ce carnaval purement
dunkerquois mais je pense qu'on est
tributaire d'un autre succès et il faut
quand même savoir qu on a intérêt je
crois au niveau notamment des grands
bals pour les associations de continuer
à ce que cela que se sache
et puis après tout les mélanges sont
jamais fait de mal à personne sauf peut
être à la tête